for many people when they think of
misery they think of the infamous
hobbling scene a scene were author Paul
Sheldon taken prisoner by his
self-proclaimed number-one fan is
hobbled to prevent any attempts at
escaping but the scene we saw in the
movie is just tame compared to the
torture that Paul indoors in the novel
stick around to the end of this video to
find out why his journey was so painful
[Music]
one of Stephen King's strengths as a
writer is writing what he knows as a
result we've seen and created a lot of
characters who are authors like Jack
Torrance Bill den bro and many others
these writers sometimes serve as a link
between his fictional stories and his
own experiences of course the fictional
characters are heavily dramatized but
there are still parallels we can draw
welcome to horror history today we're
looking at the renowned author of the
best-selling misery books Paul Sheldon
to fully appreciate Paul struggle I'm
going to take it all the way back to his
birth
the son of a vacuum cleaner salesman
Paul Sheldon was born in 1945 he was
raised in suburban Boston so his family
often took him to Revere Beach when he
was young he always insisted that they
sit by a piling in the water that looked
like the thing of a monster so he could
keep an eye on it as the tide rolled in
and out on one occasion he cut his foot
on a bottle on the sand and he cried
causing his father to tell him it was
just a little cut and to stop acting
like someone had cut his foot off if
only he knew the first movie he saw as a
kid was banded and just as bandy would
have to learn to live in the forest
without the care of his parents Paul
would one day become very dependent on
Annie for his own survival during one
childhood trip to the Boston zoo his
mother took him to see a bird from
Africa and young Paul cried because he
knew the bird would die in a cage far
from home and he thinks about this again
when he finds himself in a faraway
prison for a couple summers his mom sent
him to day camp at Malden Community
Centre where he first played a game
called Canyon the camp counselor would
start a story where a character isn't
some kind of predicament and then pick a
camper at random and they would have 10
seconds to continuance the campers would
then vote if it was plausible if you
mess up you have to leave the circle
Paul was quite good at this game and
it's probably a big reason he was able
to make it as an author of fiction it
was basically a never ending game of Ken
when Paul was 12 years old during summer
vacation his dad was working and his mom
went to go spend the day with mrs. Cass
Brak from across the street this is
probably not the same mrs. Cass Brackett
Sonique Asprey the mother of Eddie from
it's because Paul would have been 12 in
the year 1957 and as far as we know
Sonya and Eddie were living in Derry
Maine at the time so it may be that
Eddie had other relatives near Boston
anyway when Paul's parents are gone he
smokes one of his mom's cigarettes and
the room filled up with smoke just as
she came back having forgotten her purse
this could just be seen as juvenile
curiosity but it may have been a warning
of the addiction problems that Paul
would deal with later in life he was a
heavy smoker for years in his adulthood
that fall he finished reading William
Golding's Lord of the Flies and found
himself rushing to the bathroom to throw
up moments later on his 14th birthday
his father gave him a condom telling him
to put it in his wallet apparently
because he didn't want to see his son in
the army by age 16 Paul cites this as
one of the few instances where his dad
paid in much attention in high school
Paul played baseball but wasn't much
good at it due to his inability to hit a
curveball he grew up to be a tall man
with sandy colored hair he didn't go far
for college and one night at 3:00 a.m.
he received a call from his mother who
told him to come home because his father
had had a stroke he drove his old Ford
wagon 70 miles per hour but was too late
and lost one of his parents at a very
young age as a side note the Ford
station wagon was the same car that
Stephen King drove when he was college
age as explained in a 2002 article he
wrote in The New Yorker Paul's first
wife was named Eileen and they went to
Maui for their honeymoon where they
experienced a luau where a pig was
roasted over an open fire it's unclear
if this was before after his wedding but
in his prime Paul was a best-selling
author he was featured in People
magazine after writing his first
bestseller then he ended up in US
magazine after his first divorce he
ended up getting a second wife and a
second divorce such is the life of a
famous writer although king himself will
celebrate his 50th anniversary in 2021
so maybe that's just a trope Paul owns
homes in both New York and Los Angeles
which he was able to afford based on the
success of his most popular book series
the misery novels a romance series set
in the Victorian era that follows the
crazy adventures of misery Chastain and
her suitors Ian and Geoffrey though
misery proved to be his cash cow Paul
grew to hate misery since the 3rd book
because he felt the series distracted
critics from what he considered to be
his real work he also got tons of fan
mail the craziest of which he considered
to be a one page letter from a mrs.
Roman D Virginia Sandpiper who included
seven polaroid photos of original
furnishings in her recreation of
misery's parlour / study he made the
mistake of replying and was hit with
another letter this time 10 pages with
40 Polaroids Paul didn't answer this one
but that didn't stop her from following
up with at least five more letters the
marriage thing may have been made up but
I can definitely see Stephen King
projecting something by including these
details personally as far as fan art
goes I still love receiving them and I'm
flattered every time wonder if King has
ever seen an episode of horror history
Paul is open with his friends and
acquaintances about the fact that he
doesn't take the misery book seriously
and on April Fool's Day in 1983 he sent
a Mach booklet to some of them which was
titled miseries hobby which presumably
made fun of his own character as he got
older the addictive side of him took a
stronger hold and he was often out bar
Bing smoking a lot of cigarettes and
sleeping with multiple women this slowed
down his productivity behind the
typewriter and while I was only
speculating about the fan mail being
inspired from kings real experiences
this is something that was definitely
stemmed from his real life at least the
drug addiction part of it I would go so
far as to say that this is what misery
is about more than anything else that is
misery the Stephen King novel not misery
the Paul Sheldon novel in his 2000
memoir on writing King admits that he
dealt with serious drug and alcohol
problems in the 80s and barely remembers
writing Kujo or the Tommyknockers and
misery came out the same year as the
latter King feels that his writing
improved after he got his act together
and this is the most important takeaway
for Paul's character as the habits
prevent him from reaching his full
potential while we know that miseries
child was his ninth novel overall we
don't know exactly how many misery books
there are but we do know about several
of them I'm assuming the first book is
just titled misery because Paul at one
point refers to it in his head is the
first misery book rather than giving it
a proper title other titles mentioned
include miseries quest and miseries love
the movie details way more misery books
that we see in Annie's collection but
for this video we're sticking to the
Canon of the book Paul killed off the
title character at the end of miseries
child and celebrated because this meant
he would never have to write another
misery book again or so he thought
after severing himself from the misery
franchise Paul got an idea for a new
book one day in New York City after
walking past and attending to the
parking lot trying to Jimmy his white
and do a car the project would be called
fast cars and feature a car thief named
Tony bonus arrow from East Harlem in New
York he started work on this one in 1985
when he turned 40 years old he
interviewed crash victims as part of the
research for the books finale and as
with all of his books he did not create
a backup copy of the manuscript he would
spend two years working on it and as
part of his personal tradition for
finishing a book once he got close to
the end he moved his operation to the
Bull Dorado Hotel in Colorado where he
would enjoy a cigar and a bottle of
champagne he considered fast cars to be
his best work and the day before its
completion he deposited a $450 cheque at
the Boulder Bank for a little spending
money not knowing that he'd have nothing
to spend the majority of it on for quite
some time the book was finished in mid
to late February 1987 a snowstorm was
brewing in the area but meteorologists
predicted that it would turn and go
south
so Paul figured this was the perfect
chance to beat the weather and start
back to New York while he still could
however he rushed out a little too
quickly after drinking the champagne and
ended up regrettably driving under the
influence
that's one of the factors that led to
his car accident it happened on route 9
when he leaned forward to get his
cigarette temporarily taking his eyes
off the road the events that would
follow would completely change his life
and I find it to be a symbol for King's
addiction problems and that the crash
was effectively caused by two things
alcohol and cigarettes the next thing he
knew his 1974 Camaro
sending him off the mountain road and
down a Schwartz look for his car buried
itself in the snow luckily our perhaps
unluckily for him someone heard his
screams
her name was Annie Willis and she
claimed to be his number one fan she may
have saved his life with the CPR she
performed on him and one of the last
things that he remembered was her stinky
breath as she did so which was also
symbolic because yes she was helping him
stay alive but her hospitality always
came with unwanted side effects Paul
passes out and she brings him back to
her remote house where he goes into a
respiratory depression for the next two
weeks she feeds him through an IV and he
doesn't come out of the coma until early
March waking up in severe pain to find
that his legs are shattered he's in
constant pain but at times it's more
noticeable than others she does give him
a pain pill called an overall but its
main ingredient as codeine a highly
addictive opioids that Paul becomes
addicted to his body begins to need the
drug despite the bad side effects just
as he needs Annie and despite her bad
side effects I say that because Annie
has a crazy case of borderline
personality disorder and Paul is just as
much a prisoner as he is her patient
just as a drug addict may become a
prisoner of the drugs he or she is taken
no drill is a fictional drug you won't
find it at your local Walgreens or the
back alley that you go to there is a
different thing called an overall but I
can get some more recent and not a pain
medication but I think the name no rule
was named as such as a reference to
Paul's other addiction novels when Paul
starts to lose hope writing becomes the
only thing that keeps him going and
helps him cope with his pain and he had
also rescued some of Paul's things from
the car wreck and asked if she can read
fast cards a permission that he grants
the next day she criticizes it after
having read 40 pages in particular the
use of profanity which was not present
in the misery novels bothers her she
gets really worked up about it and
throws Paul's soup bowl against the wall
where it shatters making a
recommendation that he sticks to the
misery books Paul's in a lot of pain and
asked for his Novarum but she torches
him by making him wait all afternoon
because she's busy cleaning up the mess
made by the soup bowl a mess that she
blames him for making when she finally
gives him the pills she forces him to
wash it down with rinse water from the
cleaning buckets addicts are often
characterized with the common phrase
my fix Annie's insistence that he do
something disgusting like that if he
wants the pain medication establishes
the control that Annie and the Nova will
have over him when he wakes up the next
morning Annie is not okay because she
just read the ending of miseries child
where misery dies and she's a little bit
pissed off at Paul for killing off her
favorite character just a little upset
and he nearly bashes him with a water
pitcher and flings it at the door unable
to control her anger she decides it's
unwise to be around him and leaves to go
to what she refers to as her laughing
plays she would be gone for the next 51
hours which Paul kept track of by making
marks on his arm during this time he
discovered his splinted legs which were
in worse shape than he thought and in a
desperate attempt to relieve his bladder
and thirst he's actually forced to go
all Joey salads and funnel his urine
into a cup and drink it this is again a
metaphor for the extremes that an addict
is willing to go to whether he likes it
or not
Annie's hospitality is his drug when she
finally returns he's in great pain after
not having taken any medication for over
two days she brings in a charcoal grill
and asked Paul to burn his manuscript
for fast cars the results of his last
two years of work and refuses to give
him any food or no virile until he does
so after a long struggle he cooks the
book and this represents one of the
later stages of addiction where it
starts to affect loved one Paul doesn't
have any family so we see this
represented by him destroying the one
thing that he cares most about there's
even a moment where he asks Annie to do
it for him you burn it then he yelled at
her she turned and looked at him no she
said I cannot do that as much as I would
like to spare you the agony you feel why
not because she said primly you must do
it of your own free will
after this she puts him in a wheelchair
cleans his bed and gives him a sponge
bath he's able to estimate that there's
somewhere between 15 and 45 miles away
from the town of Sidewinder based on her
trips and figures his crashed car is
probably in a similar radius but maybe
buried in snow so he holds out for the
spring melt the next morning she brings
in an old royal typewriter that he
refers to as an antique the N key is
missing which according to this book
3000 facts about horror movies by James
Egan is a reference to one of Stephen
King's first typewriters which had the
same problem that's fact 1855 if you're
curious
he asked what he'll writes with this
high-tech piece of machinery already
knowing what she'll probably say a new
novel just for her and called
reads return he asked if she'll let him
go when he's done to which she responds
you speak as though I were keeping you
prisoner Paul which she is but I like
how that line fits into the drug
metaphor where an addict can technically
stop anytime they want but it's very
difficult because their bodies become
dependent on the drug this novel was to
be her payment for nursing him but his
time would not be the only thing that
Paul has to give up Paul explains that
he'll need a nanny to fetch her other
misery books as reference since he
doesn't have his concurrence hoping to
win some points with her by sharing some
behind-the-scenes other stuff but she
surprisingly doesn't seem that
interested when she brings him dinner
that night he asked that she turned to
the typewriter away from him as part of
a superstition but the real reason was
that he didn't like the way that its
teeth were almost a grinning at him the
following morning she shakes him awake
to serve him his breakfast excited for
him to begin the novel and Paul comes to
the realization that he might actually
have a chance at survival if she wants
to read the end of miseries return as
much as he thinks she does before
starting he asked her for a different
type of paper this is where the mind
games between Paul and Annie have really
began he thinks that he's trying to
stall so he doesn't have to start
writing and he tries to establish the
idea that there's a lot about writing
that she doesn't know about for example
he asked her to bring him that Webster
pons and when she doesn't know what that
is he says it's another name for a jar
of pens and pencils named after someone
named Daniel Webster I find that
hilarious and I'll definitely be using
that from now on I'm trying to figure
out what the youtuber equivalent of that
would be like how about this mini tripod
we call it broad bugs named after Chris
broad damn result is an awkwardly named
product the idea behind confusing her
was that it would calm her anger because
it was harder to be upset about
something that she did not understand
and it does work to some extent he
demonstrates that the paper she got
causes smudging and although she agrees
to buy him a new pack she does get quite
upset well get your stupid maker you
just better start showing me a little
more appreciation around your
[Music]
in the book she punches him in me and
threatens to hurt him again if he tries
to trick her before storming out however
when she marched forward to attack him a
bobby pin fell out of her hair and he
used it to unlock the door but it broke
just as he wiggled it open when he gets
through the door he imagines her
standing there with a shotgun which was
the first sign of his paranoia and
hallucinations starting to kick in he
finds her no virile stash in the
downstairs bathroom and after taking
them he becomes self aware of his own
situation he realized the medication
wasn't just working on his legs he had
gotten his fix if he wanted to be
perfectly vulgar about it he steals five
boxes which he thinks will go unnoticed
and plans to hide them under his
mattress before going back he looks for
a phone in the living room but when he
finds it it isn't operational here in
your car he hurries back accidentally
bumping into the door from his he did so
when she gets back he acts like he's
been in a lot of pain to cover up the
fact that he's covered in sweats from a
mad dash back to the room so she gives
him another two pills which he has to
take to keep up his side of the story
and shortly after taking them he falls
unconscious for 14 hours in terms of the
drug addiction analogy this represents
an overdose the next day marks the third
week of him being at Annie's and the
beginning of another snowstorm and two
days after that the first chapter of
miseries return is complete the goal of
this chapter is of course to explain the
return of the series title character who
had died at the end of miseries child in
the previous book the character Jeffrey
Road for a doctor but his horse tripped
on a toll gate so he never made it and
the doctor never showed up and this one
he writes the doctor showing up to save
Missouri's life and Annie sees this as a
cheat so it's back to square one for
Sheldon he feels drowsy at the
typewriter and decides it would be a
good idea to cut back on his novel
addiction he plans to hide one of the
two pills each time she gives them to
him so he can start to wean off of it he
decides I'll start tomorrow but then
pushes it back to after he has an
acceptable first chapter this mindset
represents a common coping tactic used
by smokers and other drug addicts they
think they can slowly get themselves off
of it but will continually put it off
once the day comes having a small amount
of a drug that they've come off of can
lead a person to ever relapse
causing them to have to start all over
just as Paul was about to start chapter
1 all over on March 25th
Paul is 6 chapters in and this time
Annie approves of the content and says
it's fair he finds that this is the most
gruesome of the misery books and thinks
it's probably because he's in a gruesome
state of mind in the afternoon he
pondered
what to do about the black marks and the
doorframe the spot where his wheelchair
had hit when he snuck out of the room he
thinks that if she hasn't noticed them
already it's likely that she will soon
just then she rushes into the room with
handcuffs in a dust cloth she cuffs him
to the headboard and gags him with the
cloth so that he can't make any noise
and she orders him not to make a sound
as a car pulls up Paul sees an older man
get out and talk to Annie just outside
of his line of sight and he hears her
get very angry with him meanwhile he
tastes the cleaning chemicals leftover
on the rag and has to fight back
vomiting and subsequently choking
himself after the guy leaves she paces
around Paul's room in a furious rage
mumbling something about a 10% tax
increase a fee and a lien on her house
she finally takes out the rag and Paul
is dry heaving as she does so he
examines the document that the guy had
given her and explains that she missed a
tax payment on her house and she still
has a chance to resolve it by the end of
the day Paul realizes he has an
opportunity to get in her good graces
here another example of him playing mind
games to try to improve his situation
his goal is to give her a false sense of
security around him by giving her the
idea that he's on her side so he offers
to give her the $400 left in his wallet
the money from the check that he cashed
the day before the crash additionally
she'd have to go into town to make the
payment and he planned to sneak out
again and get more materials to clean up
the marks in the doorframe while she was
gone before she leaves he asked her to
put him in the wheelchair so he can
write and when she's gone he accesses a
stash of bobby pins that he'd been
hiding under the mattress he was able to
pick the lock again and retrieve some
Kleenex which he used a white boy the
marks with water not wanting to push his
luck any further that day he went back
to writing this is a small detail but I
think it shows that he's starting to be
broken in by Annie's overbearing
attitude earlier that month he was
willing to risk being caught out of the
room for much longer but now he was
afraid to explore much at all and the
reason that he doesn't want to get
caught is not just that he thought that
she'd be upset at him for sneaking past
the locked door but also as a part of
the mental manipulation that he's been
trying to use on her he still wants her
to think that he's broken and helpless
so that when the time comes he can
really surprise her with his strain
he's also been secretly working out his
arms when she's out of the room by
lifting the heavy typewriter up and down
now that he's cutting back on his intake
of pills his productivity also increases
and he's able to write an astounding 12
pages per day by April 15th he's got 267
pages but that day he would discover a
horrible secret about his captor
when Annie Wilkes comes into Paul's room
on April 15 she looks like he completed
Matt she was covered in streaks of goo
and had a bloody lip as she threw the no
furu pills across the room to Paul he
asked her if she's okay and she tells
him no she tells him no she leaves the
room and he hears her slapping herself
outside she did not come in to put him
in his wheelchair that morning
the pills had relieved his first fix but
he's still pining for a second fix
writing I think for Paul writing
symbolically represents a substitute
something someone may use to relieve
their cravings when trying to quit
smoking usually in the form of gum candy
or even a fake cigarette for subscribing
the C's world on you because he's become
psychologically dependent on the hormone
release that he associates with writing
he's unable to stop himself and getting
himself into the wheelchair even though
he knows it's in his best interest not
to let any know that he has the strength
to do this unfortunately for him and he
was looking at him through the keyhole
and she screams at him if he's capable
of getting in the chair he can fill in
his own ends the slip up throws Paul off
of his pace he ends up not getting much
done and going back to bed he wakes up
that afternoon with an e by his bedside
and a completely psychotic stage she has
a cup full of pills and an injured rat
in a trap which he kills with her bare
hand and offers to get her gun and put
Paul on herself out of their misery as
well coincidentally it would be misery
in the character that saves Paul's what
he tells her he wants to finish the book
and she agrees that it's the only thing
she has left to look forward to in life
she then except the rats blood from her
fingers you think a nurse would be a
little bit more conscious about to
disease she has to go away to her
laughing place for a while and doesn't
know how long she'll be gone so two
hours later Paul picks the lock to the
guest room door to find a huge mess of
dishes and the remains of several
unhealthy snacks her ceramic figures
were also thrown about the room he looks
for a possible escape method but Annie
has installed three locks on every door
he retrieved some food from the pantry
and just enough to sustain him while she
was gone without her hopefully noticing
that he'd taken any on the way back to
his room he notices a scrapbook with the
words memory lane it contains newspapers
documenting Annie's entire life
most of them consisted of her most
likely killing her patients at the
various nursing jobs that she held over
years the final page is an article from
Newsweek author Paul Sheldon 42 reported
missing Paul thinks to himself that it's
almost like reading his own obituary
that seems to be a concept that King
kind of likes I'm reminded of its where
Ritchie discovers the flyer for the
Richie Tozier all dead Rock Show but I
think this moment more than anything is
supposed to represent a wake-up call I
imagine when King was dealing with his
own addiction problems there was
something like this a moment that made
him realize that if he continued down
the same path he was not going to make
it in the late 80s King would take the
steps to kill his addictions and on
April 16th Paul would brainstorm some
ideas to kill Annie and ultimately
decides on the simple tactic of stealing
a knife from the kitchen and hiding it
until she gets back but Paul was fast
asleep the next morning at 4:00 a.m.
when she returned and discovered what he
had done when he eventually starts to
wake up she injects him with a needle
that slowly numbs his entire body she
tells him there's good news and bad news
but the good news is just that Paul's
car disappeared in the spring runoff
after the snow melted which is actually
bad news for Paul because he was
counting on them eventually finding his
car in order to hopefully locate him the
bad news is much worse Annie had not
only discovered the broken chunk of
bobby pin that he used to sneak out the
first time he left the room but she had
also set up threads all over the house
that were now broken proving that he'd
been rummaging around she explains the
story of the Kimberly diamond mine where
the British would injure the native
workers if they tried to steal ensuring
that they could continue to work but
they would not be able to run the
operation was called hopping and that's
exactly what Annie plans to do to Paul
ensuring that he could finish her book
without fear of him running away the
mine that she mentioned is actually
located in Kimberley South Africa
coincidentally fitting in with the
metaphor of Paul being a caged African
bird far away from home an idea that
he'd been channeling in his writing by
making the bulk of misery's return take
place in Africa the hobbling scene in
the movie is already considered one of
the most uncomfortable horror scenes but
what happens in the book takes it at
least two steps further
she slathers his leg and betadine and
pulls out an axe which he uses to cut
through his ankle on her second hat
then she pulls out a bloater and uses it
to cauterize the wound before finally
dumping a bucket of water over the burn
to blacken stump that had once been an
angle in order to put out the flame Paul
passed out as she left the room and was
in a semi-comatose State for a week he
was barely breathing because of the
heavy doses of pain medication when he
eventually got back to work he was only
able to sit up in short spurts so he
didn't get as much done some unspecified
amount of time passes and it's either
May or June when anni brings in ice
cream sundaes and essentially tries to
bribe Paul into telling her the rest of
the story of misery's return which he of
course refuses giving her a reason to
keep him alive at least long enough to
finish writing it afoot would not be the
only body part he lost
Annie's next acquisition would be even
more evil than the first I started one
day when he complained about the antique
typewriter and it's missing n so Annie
decided to give him something else to
worry about he heard her having a fits
in the kitchen and she came back with
the disinfectants the numbing agent and
an electric knife despite Paul screams
and pleas his thumb was gone by that
evening this must have been especially
painful for Paul considering his entire
livelihood depends on typing and writing
the book was the only thing that was
able to distract him from the pain of
his broken legs and severed foot but it
gets worse than that though because that
evening she brought in a cake and
started singing him happy birthday there
was just one issue with this his
so-called number-one fan probably knows
this she told him if you promise to be
good Paul you can have a piece of
birthday cake but you won't have to eat
any of this special candle on June 21st
another character falls out of the
typewriter but this time he doesn't dare
complain the letter e falls out soon
after which sucks because that's the
most commonly used letter in the English
language over a month after losing his
thumb and Paul wakes up to the sound of
a car in the driveway and discovers that
it's a police car by all means this
should have been the end of Paul's now
five months of captivity but we end up
seeing the psychological effects of
Annie's treatment of him here more than
ever
he's been fantasizing about being
rescued for so long that at first he
thinks it's only in his imagination then
when he realizes that it's real he finds
that he's been conditioned not to say
anything because of the abusive
punishments like leaving him home alone
with no food or medicine chopping off
his foot and cutting off
thumb he's physically unable to bring
himself to scream because some part of
his brain is anticipating Annie's
punishments and holding him back after
several moments of internal struggle
he's able to finally belt out the first
word that comes to his head the cop
hears it but seems uncertain as to where
the sound came from so Paul
grabs a ceramic ashtray from off the
table and throws it through the window
the cop cross checks a photograph to
confirm that it's the missing author
Paul Sheldon
but unfortunately for Paul the
realization comes to Dwayne Kushner was
the cop that set out to go door-to-door
looking for leads about the location of
Paul Sheldon that afternoon he had not
expected to come across the man he was
looking for but upon the shock of the
revelation that he'd done just that
Annie stabbed him multiple times with a
cross before he's able to draw his gun
this was a worst-case scenario for Paul
who is reaching a state of extreme
desperation he considers going to the
kitchen to get a knife which he could
use to threaten to slit his wrists
effectively holding himself and the end
of Missouri's return hostage but then he
notices that the cop is still alive and
tries to warn him that she's coming back
but Annie ends up running the guy over
with a rideable lawnmower
even after watching his own body parts
get dismembered this ends up being what
pushes Paul over the edge and causes him
to vomit after cleaning the mess Annie
tells him that she's not going to kill
him but she does move him down to the
basement cellar so she doesn't have to
worry about someone finding him while
she goes and hides at the officers car
she does warn him that she took the
officers handgun and if he tries
anything when more police come looking
for him
she won't hesitate to shoot them and
then kill Paul in herself she makes up a
whole scenario to tell the cops where
she's supposedly sent the officer on his
way she explains her plan in great
detail to Paul so that he realizes that
they're now in hot water and his time to
finish the novel is limited she doesn't
allow him to have a light so he can
continue working while she's gone which
is distressing for him because he's
afraid of the rats that filled the
cellar and because he knows that he
needs to keep his mind occupied with
writing in order to get his fix any
psychological intimidation impacts him
again that night he can't stop thinking
about Duane's death and feels guilty for
being partially responsible because
Annie would have had no reason to kill
the guy if he hadn't been tipped off
while she's gone he discovers that the
basement is where Annie keeps the grill
that she made him burn fast cars on he
finds the can of lighter fluid and hides
it in the back of his underpants hoping
she doesn't notice when she carries him
back up the stairs the next morning she
doesn't and when she's out of the room
he hides it behind a loose piece of
baseboard on the wall I find this kind
of ironic on a metafictional level and
I'm pretty sure that it's intentional
because the reason that Annie rejects
his first attempt at chapter one is
because it contradicts with the previous
misery novel she goes on to explain that
she doesn't care if an artist pulls a
solution out of thin air as long as it's
fair Paul identifies this as a deus ex
machina which he considers to be kind of
an outdated writing technique but
ultimately he has to use it to make a
first chapter that Annie will accept and
in a way King is kind of doing the same
thing here because the loose piece of
baseboard where he hides the lighter
fluid has never mentioned before he just
brings it up because it's convenient
hiding place now that the space
underneath the mattress has been
compromised
the State Police do show up the next day
to man named wicks and McKnight's though
Paul refers to them as David and Goliath
because he doesn't know their names they
asked some questions and poked around a
bit but Paul doesn't strain afterwards
Annie asked why and he tells her that he
just wants to finish the book in
relative peace his real motivation was
that he thought there was maybe a 20%
chance that she's able to catch them off
guard and maybe get the quick draw on
both of them
in which case she would probably also
kill Paul and herself
so after everything that she had put him
through he was starting to want more
than to simply get her thrown in jail he
had a plan to hurt her in a way that
only he could the next five days were
filled with visitors coming to look at
Annie's house after hearing that she was
suspected in relation to Duane Kushner's
disappearance curious people and news
crews and teenagers showed up at the
house and Paul made sure to stay out of
sight of each of them not wanting to get
any more innocent people killed on the
fourth and fifth evenings Paul stays up
writing until dawn after which the day
of the novel's completion would finally
arrive and he brings in a celebratory
caviar and Paul a sir that he be allowed
one cigarette along with the celebratory
champagne that he usually indulges in as
part of his tradition for finishing a
book she reluctantly allows it and as
Paul expects she doesn't want to be
around when he snow exists so she leaves
him with one match to light it with and
after finally finishing the book that he
never wanted to write in the first place
he puts his plan into action first he
takes the real manuscript and hides it
under the bed then he takes the cover
page and puts it over an empty stack of
papers he douses it with the lighter
fluid and calls Annie back into the room
one last time as soon as she entered she
catches the smell of the lighter fluid
and freezes but when Paul strikes the
match it doesn't light not until the
third attempt and as soon as Annie
realizes what he's trying to do she
screams drops the expensive champagne
and charges him to tried to stop it as
it goes up in flames Paul tells her that
it was the best thing he ever wrote and
as she reaches down to try to save the
burning pages he strikes her in the back
of the head with the typewriter which
weighs nearly fifty pounds this knocks
her down into the flames
he can smell her skin burning as she
bellows but that was worth things
stopped going according to plan she rose
back up but tripped over the typewriter
so Paul fell on her and stuffed her
mouth full of ashes she's unable to stop
him for some time when she finally bucks
him off she ends up tripping on the
typewriter for a second time and this
time her head strikes the mantelpiece
and knocks her out but like a nightmare
Annie Wilkes just won't die and he ends
up having to pry himself away from her
something that he's only able to do
because the leg that she grabbed had no
foots to hold on to he crawls into the
bathroom and locks himself in there he
takes three capsules of no virile and
that is what we call a relapse
eventually he wakes up and realizes that
he can't hide in the bathroom forever
he's unsure if she's still alive but
when he opens the bathroom door Annie
and
axé are waiting for him the National
Institute of Mental Health defines
post-traumatic stress disorder as a
disorder that develops in some people
who have experienced a shocking scary or
dangerous event in my opinion the months
that Paul spent living in the house of
Annie will it's contained all three of
these prerequisites for these reasons
PTSD was hitting Paul hard as he tried
to escape the house after first
imagining Annie waiting for him outside
of the bathroom his mind interpreted her
standing in nearly every shadow as he
crawled his way back to the parlor when
he got there the Colorado State Police
had returned and he called out to them
for help upon discovering him they think
that he looks like a nightmare come to
life remember at this point they thought
Paul was most likely dead they were
mostly here to find the missing officer
Dwayne Kushner when the bigger of the
two cops Wix recognizes Paul he can only
remember him as the missing Rice Christ
can't you see Wix asked it's the guy
Kushner was looking for the writer I
can't remember his name but it's him
thank God the scrawny man said what
wakes bents toward him frowning thank
God you can't remember my name
the cops are confused by his reaction
but the reason that Paul is relieved is
that his fame is what got him into this
mess in the first place and he claimed
to be his number one fan and that
influenced a lot of her actions so he
was glad that his rescuers were not fans
because he just wanted to be treated
like a normal human being we next see
Paul nine months later somewhere around
April 1988 he's got a new apartment in
Manhattan and he still has to make
frequent visits to the hospital he could
walk again but he would have a limp for
the rest of his life unfortunately after
his novel relapse in Annie Wilkes
bathroom he had gone into a bit of a
spiral with lots of drinking and not a
lot of writing he still misses getting
his fix of Novarum on the bright side
his publisher fast-tracked his novel The
Prince due to the massive wave of media
attention garnered from his story
becoming a national headline an
unprecedented 1 million first copies
were made so this would easily be his
biggest success he has lunch with his
editor
Charlie Merrill who begs him for a
nonfiction account of his story and
estimates they could make at least 10
million dollars on it Paul tries to
imagine himself doing that and thinks he
would probably start off his nonfiction
but then slowly started to fudge stuff
because he's a fiction writer at her
after lunch he walks home because his
doctor wants him to practice walking for
a mile each day so after everything he
really ended up back where he started an
addict relying on alcohol to get him
through the day and not living up to his
full potential on the way back he sees
the kid pushing a caged skunk in a
shopping cart which is a strange sight
even for New York City this gives him an
idea when he gets home he takes an
aspirin instead of drinking and for the
first time in over a year seriously gets
to work on a new novel about a New
Yorker who discovers a skunk in his
apartment there is a poetic symmetry to
the way that he starts his new novel
when he started fast cars the treasured
one that Annie made him burn it was also
because of something he had seen while
walking in New York so I think the
meaning of this ending is that the
entire traumatic experience taught him
that he's better off without the drugs
and this is him moving on and getting
back to his healthy addiction creating
novels Paul is one of the most personal
characters that King has ever written
it's definitely not easy to create a
gateway character to represent himself
and be as honest as he was about all of
his flaws we would however see a new
take on the character portrayed by the
actor James can and the film adaptation
of misery that is the film adaptation of
the Stephen King novel not the film
adaptation of the Paul Sheldon novel so
join me in the next video as I break
down everything you might have missed in
misery remember to subscribe to see Z's
world for new Horrors every week bring
that death bell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
stay inside